welcome to this week's edition of world
stories Poland preparing for the worst
Germany drawing fire but we begin the
show in the United States over 200
people were killed by firearms in the
washington DC metro area last year many
of them young afro-americans Malik was
just one week shy of his 16th birthday
when a stranger shot him in the neck on
a public bus following a teenage spat
his mother Sharon SAT by his bedside in
hospital for four days and nights then
three days before his birthday Malik's
brain failed and the machines were
turned off forever Sharon remembers the
last time she spoke to her son it was a
good moment he was meeting me at my
daughter school and he came and you know
gave me a big hug told me he loved me
and you know then went on his way and I
went on to work and I just never knew
there wasn't be my last hug from him and
kiss from him but that's how he always
greets me or that's how he always leaves
me before big hug and kiss and tells me
he loves me so that was the last time
that I greeted him there is no morning
when Sharon does not wake up without
tears in her eyes what does she feel
when she thinks about her son's murderer
and can a jail sentence ever bring
justice it's hard to put years on my
son's life cuz my son will never come
back and um but that's the only thing
that they can do is give him years so
it's just hard at the end of every year
Lisa de littie writes on t-shirts the
names dates of birth and death of each
person who has been shot dead during the
last 12 months it's a transportable
political Memorial which delete he plans
to install outside churches in Greater
Washington next year there'll be a shirt
for Moloch to each t-shirt represents a
human being and I have a problem with
the Congress that doesn't remember that
they're human beings being killed by
these guns that there are mothers and
fathers and sisters and brothers who are
not with us anymore because someone had
easy access to a gun and that we need to
do something about there seems to be
little in this bitterly contested
election year that could offer some hope
to parents like Sharon that they won't
have to live in fear of losing another
child to gun violence
NATO has been conducting maneuvers in
Poland and for the first time polish
paramilitary forces will be given a role
part of Warsaw strategy to counter what
it sees as a growing threat along its
eastern border with Russia a quiet
courtyard in watts of inside a small
apartment a meeting place for this group
of friends there studying security
policy and international relations today
like every weekend they're preparing to
spend their free time doing military
exercises we're getting our equipment
together the backpacks the guns the
ammunition now we're going to check that
we have everything and that it'll all
work properly when we get to the drill
ground good preparation is really
important bigelow their military
equipment including arms and ammunition
are just imitations but at the training
ground they take the exercises very
seriously despite the 35 degree heat the
group is off to a forest about 15
kilometers outside of watts love they
organize and finance these trips
themselves in the run-up to this week's
NATO summit the Polish government has
announced it once to integrate the
country's 40,000 volunteer soldiers into
its new national defense plan they'll
become a recognized part of the Polish
army mamando janina's ogromnoe model
this interest in national security has
become a kind of trend particularly
among young people we want to make the
most of that but these different groups
are operating on very different levels
from the equipment they have to the
exercises they do it's all dependent on
their own funding that's why the defense
ministry wants to provide financial
support to bring standards in line we
believe in the principle if you want
peace prepare for war the brats love
students have been practicing drills and
the Blazing Sun for hours for them the
potential enemy is clear like most poles
they believe that if it came to it the
threat would come from the east
lot of names I got a hernia Putin
definitely poses a danger I don't know
if it would really come to an attack but
if it did we'd all be ready to defend
Poland is key after the NATO summit the
defence ministry wants to provide
financial support for the paramilitary
groups everyone who officially registers
as a defender of the nation and takes
part in training exercises will get the
equivalent of one hundred and twenty
euros a month that's good news for the
students from Bratislava
Germany now and the political cartoonist
zuna from Malaysia back home has been
charged with sedition and faces a
lengthy prison sentence for lampooning
his country's leaders but he's refusing
to be cowered sightseeing in Berlin but
sukhothai Anwar uh lock from Malaysia is
not a typical tourist he's here to
garner support using the pseudonym zunar
he published caricatures critical of the
government in his native country now he
could face a 43 year prison sentence it
is a dookie for cartoonists to expose
corruption and injustice in anywhere
including in Malaysia zeuner is famous
in Malaysian he recently tweeted his
support for an opposition politician for
the authorities that was apparently the
last straw he was charged and could now
end up in jail for decades for alleged
subversive activities the law that this
verdict is based on harks back to the
colonial era his caricatures are caustic
regardless of whether they address
corruption or restrictions on press
freedom he refuses to be silenced
yes I was here I going to fish 43 years
deal I feel I'm human like anybody else
but if you ask yourself which is bigger
feel a responsibility for me
responsibility is bigger than feels
that's why he continues to fight for
himself and for freedom of expression in
Germany he is meeting with foundations
politicians and NGOs his objective is to
gain international attention and to
avoid prison zunar is no isolated case
in 2015 8 other journalists were
arrested and in February Malaysia's
largest independent online newspaper was
blocked in the global press freedom
index Malaysia ranks in the bottom
quarter zunar will also travel to
Britain and Australia to seek support
it's important for me to keep telling
myself that I'm not alone so I was
people around the world now supporting
me so this is the strength that i will
carry when I going back to malaysia his
trial is set for September if zune our
losses this could be his last visit to
Berlin
our last report takes us to Africa
cycling is a popular sport in Rwanda we
take a look at one young athlete who is
regularly ahead of the pack also
internationally meet Jean dr. ubuntu who
inspires other women to fight for their
dreams it's early morning at the
headquarters of rwanda cycling team john
dark jira bunt 0 is warming up together
with the other cyclists they have three
to four hours of training ahead of them
in Rwanda hills sean is the only woman
in team Rwanda and last year she was the
first black African woman ever to ride
at the UCI road world championships I do
court rule or i can only tell other
girls and women love the sport and
believe in your potential I never
thought that I would cycle in the USA or
Switzerland I heard about those places
but I didn't know what it was like there
I've been able to travel and meet lots
of people Jean is ambitious she needs
competition there are no other women who
were at her level so the trainer lets
her cycle would the men certain fiki
chiappa she just suddenly turned up with
a lot of talent and she seriously wanted
to be a cyclist Elise a user and she's
not only a good cyclist with prospects
but she encourages other women in Rwanda
and Africa to do sports to Malta thumb
not a lot easier juan de meo C&F peak a
visit to her home village a long way
from the training center bikes are
ubiquitous here too jean has just come
from an international competition in
morocco she tells her mother that she
has two days before she gets back to
training did a lungful number queen it
used to be difficult for me to make ends
meet I also had to pay for her bus fares
and when the bicycle was broken I had to
help her with money to get it repaired
daddy
today jean has able to help her family
up with the money she earns from cycling
she gets almost 1,000 euros a year as a
member of the national team for some
there's nothing better than coming back
to visit her family she comes to see
them every three months if you don't you
work well I'm really happy to see my
friends I really miss them it's
important for me this way when I get
back I can concentrate on the
competition and don't have to keep
thinking about when I'm finally going to
see them jean has been cycling for
Rwanda national team in Africa for two
years now she wants to take part in
races in Europe she says there are more
competitions for women there and she
hopes that her biggest dream will come
true to cycle for Rwanda in the Olympics
you